quand j'ai su que j'étais le premier à
c'était encore pire que tout ce que je
croyais que qu'il y en avait eu mais non
pas que senghor a essayé il a échoué en
normandie mais c'est lourd à porter
c'est sûr mais c'est avec plaisir
saint-coulitz est une petite commune
rurale de 360 habitants au pied de losne
tout près de châteaulin dans le
finistère
kofi yamgnane n'est venu y habiter il ya
une quinzaine d'années avec ses amis du
nouveau conseil municipal il est
d'accord pour dire que tout est à faire
dans la commune il n'y a pas de commerce
pas de café pas d'école même pas de
bourg mais koffi est disponible pour
tout le monde
koffi ne manque pas d'idées pour animer
sa commune d'adoption pour lui
l'important c'est de se rencontrer pour
se comprendre
de ce point de vue là il n'y a aucun
problème entre lui et les agriculteurs
de saint-coulitz et je pouvais
difficilement imaginer qu'une commune
rurale comme saint-coulitz pouvait
apporter comme ça
[Musique]
ma porte est à moi l'étranger l'africain
une telle confiance alors c'est
véritablement c'est difficile c'est vrai
que c'est
c'est dur à expliquer des gens qui sont
ancrés dans la terre qui sont là ne
demande rien à personne et qui prennent
comme ça quelqu'un qu'il adopte qui en
font leur fils s'est véritablement c'est
véritablement très beau
[Musique]